hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that features a most ingenious
way of countering the london system it's
a game from the ftx crypto cup round
three levon arenan vs magnus carlsen and
you guys will enjoy this one i don't
know if you remember uh last year in
january i made a video on how to beat
the london system uh with a well with a
very easy to remember setup and um
uh well
unless so
well unless white really really knows
how to counter this you should not have
any problems uh tackling this so if you
have any problems uh playing against the
london do check it out i will put this
short tutorial in the description below
it will be the first thing you will see
but this is a completely different way
of countering the london and a much more
exciting one if i may add so let's check
it out and for those of you i have seen
some of you saying in the comments that
these are not their actual ratings and
you are correct these are not their fee
day ratings uh these are their uh chest
24 ratings that um
that they are using when they are
playing online or not just 24 the
multiplayer champion chester ratings
that are also used in the ftx crypto cup
so that's why they are different from
the uh from their official feed day
ratings
some are higher rated some are lower
rated and uh well
i've seen some of you were
surprised and confused in the comments
so let's dive straight into it levon has
the white pieces and he opens with d4
uh magnus replies with uh pawn to e6 he
goes for the horde's defense we have
knight to f3 knight to f6 and now bishop
to f4 the london system is on the board
and magnus replies with bishop to e7 we
have h3 by levon and now comes pawn to
b5 now uh there are some games uh that
were played online rather there is one
game where this was played but it was an
online game but for all intents and
purposes uh you know
with considering games over the board
we can consider this a completely new
game so already as of move 4 magnus now
has plans of playing a6 and then
countering in the center with c5 and
since e3 still wasn't played levon chose
to play h3 now you can choose this b5
idea we have e3 now preparing to capture
on b5 magnus defends it knight beat to
d2 and now bishop to b7 developing the
bishop to this long diagonal bishop to
d3 by one preparing the standard setup
with c3d for e3 the knights here and the
bishops a place like this so this is
pretty much playable against uh every
defense black chooses except the one
that i have made in the description
below so here pawn to c five magnus
strikes against the center c3 and now
knight to c6 with pawn to e4 levon now
improves his
position in the center grabs more space
with d6 by magnus and now bishop back to
e3 uh castles by both lavon and magnus
and now rook the c8 by magnus
developing the rook the captures on c5
we have d capture is now attacking the
rook if levon wanted to capture on c5
maybe it would have been better to
capture a bit sooner now this uh
recapture comes with tempo so queen to
e2 defending the bishop and now of
course queen to c7 preparing to bring
this rook to d8 and then magnus will
have develo
completed his development so here ponte
a4 attacking this beautiful expansion
magnus created on the queen side and now
pawn to c4 magnus waited quite quite
some time for the c4 move
but now is the time to play at c4 bishop
to c2 and now rook f2d8
we have rook after d1 and now pawn to h6
creating some breeding room for the king
on h7 and also taking away the g5 square
from lavon's pieces as if levon can
sacrifice upon open up the light square
bishop could be very nasty as we've seen
how fiercely lavon can attack but now
it's time to attack this um
expansion magnus has on the queen side
so captures captures and pawn to b3 this
is how it's usually done
but you guys probably already know what
magnus played here c characters on b3
bishop captures and now the move that
pretty much um uh you know uh works
wonders in any position and that is pawn
to b4 uh here levon has to trade because
if you play something like c4 then uh
okay you have a pass c pawn but
carlson's uh b4 pawn is just incredible
you're gonna play some like knight d7
knight c5 put the knight here put
pressure on b3 and your position will be
incredible so here of course levon has
to trade c captures on b for knight
capture sun b4 and now we have knight to
d4
uh we have queen e5 now uh hoping that
levon plays something weird so magnus
can play rook captures on d4 he will
happily give up the rook for two pieces
but levon says nope pawn to f4 kicks
away the queen queen to b8 and now uh
well you could play a lot of good moves
here levon plays the absolute coolest
one the best one and uh
the the trickiest one for magnus to
handle and that is knight captures on e6
beautifully done giving up the knight
for two pawns uh and for uh the rook on
c8 as it would seem so f captures on e6
bishop captures with check we're gonna
pick up the c8 rook as well king the h8
bishop captures and now rook captures
and c8 and now if you count the pawns uh
ended the pieces okay uh levon has the
two rooks but the magnus has a bishop
and knight for a rook and also levon is
up to pawn so if you had to evaluate
this um
should be should be should be equal so
here rook to a7 by levon continues
playing in great style the bishop nicely
defends the a7 pawn and you are putting
immense pressure along the seventh rank
and now bishop the c5 challenging the
bishop and also the rook here so bishop
captures on c5 rook captures also it was
very important to play this move to
prevent the queen from coming to b5 that
would be very nasty with an attack on
the bishop and the knight so rook d to
e1 rugby to a1 doubling up on the a file
and now knight to c6 by magnus kicking
away the rook but first we're going to
play queen to e3 and now threaten to
pick up the rook on c5 and now rook to
c2
we have rook 7 to 84 getting the rook
out of harm's way and now queen to d8
now activating the queen by attacking
the knight on d2 so knight f3 and now
knight to e7 here magnus is preparing a
knight the knights the g6 and then the
knight will probably be able to
infiltrate maybe via the h4 square maybe
you can put more pressure on this f4
pawn with with the knight on g6 so many
things are possible also d4 pawn is
attacked and if the white pawns start
marching forward they are
they look scary but they will
of course become easier targets so here
we have queen to b3 now attacking the
rook and the bishop but this allows
magnus this very very clean queen to c7
way of handling things defends the rook
defends the bishop and now puts pressure
on the f4 pawn and also the e4 pawn is
under attack so how can levon handle
this one good way of doing it is queen
to e3 this kind of defends everything
but then you allow this knights the g6
move and this puts pressure on the f4
pawn and if f5 knight f4 and um this is
lost white can just resign this there's
uh really no good way to handle all of
the threats knights d to check is coming
rook to c1 also a possibility in some
lines the the knight can come to h5 then
to g3 this is just uh
looking looking terrible so instead
after queen to c7 we have knight to d4
eleven goes for a very tricky idea
attacks the rook and c1 magnus goes rook
to c1 check we have a trait here
captures captures we have king to h2 and
now queen the captures on f4 with check
magnus grabs one of the pawns queen to
g3 offers a queen trade and now queen
captures an e4 so this is how magnus
eliminated both of the pawns
but can levon do something now uh rook
to b4 uh putting pressure on the bishop
also the queen can never move from uh
defending the g2 pawn because this would
be checkmate uh so bishop to d5 not
allowing any uh rook captures on b7
ideas in the future even though for the
moment it's not a possibility but bishop
d5 here the bishop is nicely protected
by the knights and now magnus is just
looking for ways how do i get these two
knights as close to the white king as
possible
so here levon could play something like
knight to c6 open up a discovery to the
white queen pick up the knight here and
the game continues it's not a nice
position for levon but let's say you go
for this knight c6 attacks the queen for
example queen e6 you trade here and you
move the rook uh yes it's a two two uh
pieces against uh a rook but still maybe
you can save this however after queen to
f2 there is no good way of saving this
uh but it's also
uh important to play the absolute most
precise move so feel free to pause the
video and try to find it the only move
that gives magnus a winning position
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible maneuver with the knight and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is knight the g6 this is
what magnus played and now there is very
little levon can do knight stage 4 is
coming and there will be all of this
pressure on the g2 pawn you simply will
not be able to handle uh for example if
you play a weird move let's say rook a4
just knight a4 and that's it there's no
defense against knight captures and g2
uh all of the moves are just really
really bad for white so instead after
knight g6 lamont says uh all right i've
got nothing better knight to c2 puts
pressure on the queen queen to e7 and
now rook to d4
now uh putting pressure on this on this
bishop here
but not bishop to e4 so magnus still
just having a very very dominant
position and the knights are getting
closer and closer to the white king we
have knight to e1
and now queen to e5 with check luckily
the rook is protected so you're not
going to lose the rook king g1 and now
knight to f4 and now this knight will
come
closer as well rook to b4 and now king
to h7 magnus could also just start
bringing the knight into the game but um
you know uh let's keep keep it as clean
as possible not avoid any um background
checks it checks in the future so rook
to b3 and now knight six the d5 we have
knight to f3 attacks the queen queen to
c7 and now queen to b2 uh hoping to get
maybe some rook to b7 action going as
the queen also attacks g7 so maybe
lebron can deliver some sneaky checkmate
but magnus just moves the queen queen c5
check we have king to h2 and now uh
knight to e3 a very very nasty move now
just going after the g2 pawn if the
knight moves then of course there
there's a triple attack and there is no
move levon can play of course lavon will
try he offers a queen trade but now
magnus trades queens but in the cleanest
way possible knight f1 check king to h1
if you go for king the g1 then knights
the e2 check picks up the queen so this
is impossible so king h1 and now magnus
trades but by doing so also wins the g2
knight captures and now of course the
bishop characters and g2 with check king
to g1 and now of course the bishop
captures on h3 uh really winning in a
cool way saying that okay you can
capture the bishop and then take the
knight but uh
even if you do this captures captures
and captures i'm still have two pawns
and magnus would very happily
demonstrate how to win this elementary
end game being up at two pawns with a
knight against tonight so levon not
about to give him this pleasure he plays
rook to f3 pawn to g5 now and rook to a3
now levon is just uh you know at the
mercy of how magnus will win this
actually so king g6 we have knight to f3
and now knight the g3 we have king to h2
uh in the now knights to f5 rook to a6
with check and now king to h5 you don't
have to worry about any sneaky
checkmates as there really is no way to
pull this off knight's the e5 uh
constricting the movement of the uh of
the black king but it doesn't really
matter pawn to g4 pawn to g3 coming so
rook to a3 and now uh it would be very
very ill consider it to play g3 if you
play g3 check here uh white will be able
to to pick up the pawn and then it's a
draw for example knight captures king
captures now attacks the knight and the
bishop so if you move the knight you're
going to lose the bishop so kng5 defends
the knight but now we can harass the
black king all we want and at some point
for example knight captures here you're
going to move to e5 now we're going to
deliver a check again at some point
you're going to have to move away from
the defense of the knight and then we're
just going to trade captures captures
and it is a draw by insufficient
material so it would be a very very uh
good for levon if this happens but
magnus not about to
allow such a thing so he plays bishop to
f1 uh and now again levon has to figure
out how to play this but there there is
no no good way uh probably magnus wants
to shift the bishop over to this
diagonal to help out against the uh
attacking the white king but here rook
a4 now attacks the knight but now just
pawn the g3 with check king g1
knights to d3 and now knight to d7
uh going for knight to f6 check maybe
magnus bond or something bishop to h3
now you can see that uh carlsen's bishop
is controlling um
f1 and g2 and the pawn controls f2 and
h2 so there is very little the white
king can do if you allow magnus two
moves uh you can very easily get
checkmated for example uh knight h4 uh
knight f3 checking h1 and knight to f2
will be checkmate so if you allow that
it's game over so knight f6 checked by
lebon king the g6 this is this is a
really cool check by one because if
magnus plays king g5 which you know in a
rapid game is possible he can obtain a
draw with 94 check now king f4 knight to
c5 check opens up a discovery picks up
the knight here for example king of
three knight captures here and now uh
you are uh still down two pawns but you
have a rook and knight against the
knight in bishop so with perfect play
you will be able to draw this but again
magnus not about to allow this king to
g6 not allowing any sneaky checks with
the knight so 94 we have knights to f4
and now rook to a6 with check king to h5
now knights do f6 check king to h4 and
now rook to a4 going after the knight
here but now king g5 knights the e4
check and now king to g4 uh and that's
uh pretty much it knights the c3 was
played but here knight to h4 and it was
in this position unmove 69
that levon arunyan resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
once you make a move and it doesn't
matter what move it is let's say even
you go something like knights to e2 you
want to win the win the night here just
nice to have three check and once the
king moves the end or h1 is your only
square the bishop covers the f1 square
upon the g2 will be checkmate there's no
stopping this lavon sorry and of course
here he resigned
so uh quite an equalish game and you
know the position was just really really
wild so it could have gone uh either way
but a very very cool way of countering
the london so if you are struggling with
the london and okay this is a very
specific line as uh usually white will
play e3 uh
instead of this uh funk h3 move but if
someone does play h3
uh you should know that you can
immediately exploit this by gaining this
beautiful expansion on the queen side
with the immediate b5
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it first the game that we are
covering from round three of the ftx
crypto cup uh really hope you guys
enjoyed this one uh i would like to
thank ricky emini excellent subscriber
brendan ward johan clayson and raymond
raphael for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day